I think that's where the batteries in
what ways might you be considered an
awkward person
ah I can't even talk about sex with like
my sister and she's like the person that
I'm closest to I want you to be fully
clear here under no circumstance would I
ever even say the word sex I feel like
Mariah just wanted to publicly embarrass
me this is a video of humiliation the
question that was just posed to us was
how do we feel about Christmas and how
do we feel about combining Christmas
with sex toys initial response is not
feeling it it's Immaculate Conception
for a reason so let's unwrap some
holiday sex toys
[Music]
it's a candy cane
oh my god it's so loud it's really light
it's so loud this is the same volume as
a blender this for your for your ass or
you could insert this like from this end
yeah yeah yeah you could you could do
that or you could just like put it on
your clothes or you just jam it up in
there right - is it just me or is it
really - wow that's a name no it's candy
cane Lube I got spice me up gingerbread
personal lubricant this would literally
fill me with the holiday spirit that's
not it sorry mom
this smells so sweet that like I feel
like I get a yeast infection from it it
smells like cough drop oh my god yeah
right that's how big this one smells
like if you're having sex you're Powys
and lube so it's probably better that
that there's some festive option than no
option at all I feel embarrassed
oh my god oh hello if your eye is not
caught by a fully nude man then your I
would definitely be caught by this thing
covering up his penis and an testicle I
think this would be very hot this is so
coarse
I mean I've seen bigger but I'm pretty
glad we're done with that I felt
uncomfortable the majority of this video
shoot but I am definitely more
comfortable with with with talking about
it a little bit now as compared to
before I just think it's so silly
everything is so silly if you're
chilling with your BAE okay on Christmas
why not pull out a little little sex toy
and have some fun with that ah if my
family sees this video I like to say I'm
sorry grandpa
and Merry Christmas I know in this edit
they're gonna reframe it as like our
weeks we are nipping that in the bud
[Music]